we're live chairman
okay thank you very much
and nobody at this stage has indicated
that their raised hand icon isn't
working so i assume that i'll take from
that everybody's raised hand icon is
working
okay welcome to rochester district
council's remote
review committee meeting this evening
and welcome to anybody watching this via
the live stream
on friday the 9th of april we all
received
the very sad news of the passing of his
royal highness
prince philip duke of edinburgh in line
with guidance issued by the government
the council will continue to provide
services
and conduct its business during the
national period of mourning
we have lowered our flag to half mast as
a mark of respect
and will be streaming a two-minute
silence on friday
the 16th of april at 9 30 a.m
residents will be able to follow this
live and the link for that is on the
front page of the council's
website if anybody makes inquiries
that's where they can find the link
members
moving on to agenda item number one
which is apologies for
absence um sonia would you just be able
to confirm apologies for the season for
members please
certainly chairman we've had uh
apologies in the office from
councillor wilkinson thank you very much
um agenda item number two substitute
members
sonia are there any substitutes there
are none
okay thank you very much
item number three non-members attending
sonia again would you confirm whether
any non-members attended this evening
yes um chairman i believe we have
councillors
fd and councillor williams in in
attendance
thank you so i'm just trying to find
everybody on the screen
oh there we go yep lovely thank you very
much
item number four which are minutes of
the meeting held on the 2nd of march
2021 are the minutes agreed members
those will be signed at a later date
thank you very much i'm assuming that's
that's all good everybody looks good
great thank you agenda to number five
that's received declarations of interest
any declarations of interest including
any whipping declarations at all there
are
none thank you
moving on to item six which is approval
of the review committee's annual report
um the committee is required to report
annually to full council on its working
a draft report has been created and
circulated for members to review um
i can see that councillor mrs mason has
indicated to speak first so council mrs
mason
over to you thank you mr chairman
excuse me um yes i'm
a little bit concerned that on the page
of review committee members
um you've admitted counselor dianne hoy
i think that needs to be corrected and
she wasn't on the committee for the
whole year but she did serve and she did
seven working groups as well
so i think that oversight needs to be
corrected
okay sorry i i thought you were sorry
that council mrs mason
i thought you'd actually indicated
slightly before i thought you actually
had a question
not necessarily about the report i
thought it was a bit slow i know you
have a few it issues
um if i can just ask you to pause it i
will come back to your counselor mrs
mason
um as soon as i've finished um i just
want to um ask sonia um to actually
introduce the report to members firstly
sorry i do apologize members
um and then i'll cancel mrs mason i will
come back to you first thing
after and sonia has introduced the
report
apologies i knew it was a bit slow on my
computer i think
thank you chairman um so when the review
committee
um consider its annual report in the
last municipal year
officers were asked to review the format
of the report
which hadn't changed for a number of
years um
officers went away and looked at a
number of uh
different annual reports um uploaded to
the website for the center for
governance and scrutiny and undertook
a piece of work which has resulted
in a new format for this year's draft
report
this has incorporated feedback from
members
and the draft before members includes a
forward from the chairman
as well as listing all members of the
committee during the period covered by
the
uh draft report although this year has
been challenging in terms of meetings
the draft annual report nevertheless
provides a more detailed overview of the
work streams during this year
which was specifically requested by the
committee
at its meeting last september the draft
report was circulated to members of the
committee in advance
of publication of the agenda which was
requested at the last meeting
chairman i would like to thank the
council's democratic services officers
lauren morris and kevin smith for all
their hard work on this
um i welcome members comments chairman
and and note uh
the the um the the oversight pointed out
by councillor mrs christine mason which
will of course be rectified
and i ask that the draft annual report
be approved
so that can be received by council at
the next full council meeting
thank you chairman thank you sonya
um and and just from the chair
also just like to thank lauren and kevin
um lauren i know that we've
spoken a bit and um a few emails back
and forth which i realized and
appreciated a bit lengthy from
from me um but i thank you both for your
hard work and effort in putting together
this
report which is vastly in my opinion
improved upon last year's um or previous
years
um councillor mrs mason um i'd just like
to invite you back
to speak thank you mr chairman um
yes i do think it's a shame that a
mission was made but
i'm glad that it's going to be corrected
and
um apologies to councillor hoy that i
didn't
notice it before had i done so i would
have raised it before
and the report is
a very clear format and i think one
that's relatively easy to follow and
easy to read
however it's somewhat sanitized the
um version of what went on and there's
two things that i think um
need to be if not included in the report
because if we're going to have this but
so there's errors of permission
one of them was the peer review the
which um gave a lot of constructive
criticism
and concerns about the review committee
that seems to have been ignored
and whilst i admit we haven't uh dealt
with it it's something that should have
been dealt with and
certainly should be noted and
the other other thing that is missing is
that
last early last year i think it was
february now i'm forgetting it so long
ago
um we set up a working group we have
constantly and repeatedly
asked officers to provide that
information so that we can proceed
they have constantly and repeatedly not
done so
um we should celebrate our successes
yes that's good but we should also
acknowledge our failures thank you mr
chairman
thank you councillor mrs hoy um
i think whilst i do accept this
um whilst i do accept that the peer
review was mentioned
as you have stated it it hasn't been
discussed
review committee and reasons for that
have been given in previous meetings um
so i
i don't really think it's inclusion
within this year's report
would have would actually give any
substance um
i'll take other members comments on that
but
as far as i'm concerned i don't think
this report is is for the
inclusion of that um councillor mr hoy
yeah thank you chairman um
as someone who is quite critical of the
last report i i just wanted
to say that this is a vast improvement i
think it's very much more readable
and gives a lot more information and is
written better
and actually does although i'm still a
little bit critical of of the content it
does
cover the the things the review
committee has
looked at in in more detail than the
previous report
so um it's an improvement all around i'd
i do think that still we are
not mentioning some of the criticisms
all members have had on some areas i
mean
my view is that the we as a
committee with much more critical um
of the um
the um sorry i've lost the page i'm
working on a small cupcake
apologies for this i was very well
prepared and i've lost my pain
the um emergency planning for instance
i think as a committee we were very much
more critical of the emergency
planning and wanted more answers than
would be shown on on the report
i mean otherwise it is an improvement i
don't want to be too critical because it
is an improvement and
i just think we still i think those
council mrs mason said are perhaps
guilty of of um the omission of
some things not um really that that's
what i'll say on that matter thanks okay
thank you
cancer mr hoy councillor hookway
thank you chairman um yes um
i'm basically not going to be adding
anything um
to what some of the other members have
already said yes the
the report layout and and the way that
it's been produced is
is better than um an improv and an
improvement on previous uh
examples um however there is
some matters that have been raised which
which i think are
valid uh and perhaps need to be looked
at
um one thing which i was going to say
which is
not necessarily related to this but i
think it's
appropriate to just mention it but it's
um
it's very disappointing that uh the last
full council meeting was cancelled
um bear in mind that uh a number of
members
uh would have uh you know would be uh it
would be their last uh
um uh council full council meeting uh
like myself so
um it seems to be uh uh
something which is a um you know uh
i don't i'm not quite sure the uh the
the reasons
for for canceling uh a full council
meeting um
i've never known it to happen in the
seven years that i've been a council
member
so i think that uh that needs to be uh
noted uh it doesn't give the opportunity
i don't
sorry to sort of like
express that counselor at the last
meeting councillor
i don't think that needs to be noted in
the report for the
review committee's end of year report um
and i'm sure if you've if you want to
to raise that you can do with officers
directly um
whilst person on a personal level i
share your disappointment
i don't think it's for this evening's
meeting
um but thank you for your comments and
i'm sure that officers that
are present this evening will take that
on board
um councillor dre thank you
thank you um uh chairman um i
thought the uh reports was very good
it certainly read very well um but
following on from council
mrs mason's comment should it be noted
chairman that i joined the committee
part way through the municipal year
um i will look to sonja for that but i
see no reason why that can't be included
or lauren chairman um
we we we can look at uh that in in
in both instances that have been raised
this evening thank you
thank you i think it's a very worthwhile
comment yes
um councillor mcpherson
um thank you chairman um i totally agree
with councillor dre's comments
the report does read well um i'd like to
thank officers as well if that's okay
um chairman um to be honest it would be
impossible
to include every single comment that has
been raised throughout the year
it would be far too waiting a document
and one that people probably won't pick
up and read
my only um suggestion therefore
when people want everything to be
included
would be if you look on page 6.6
which is the calendar of the workplace
um i see no reason why perhaps
links to the actual meetings
could be included there so people could
actually
listen to the meetings or refer back to
the minutes that were taken
thank you thank you thank you that's a
good idea
um i think probably um
looking to sonja and lauren to answer
that i would think that
this um work plan that's that's possibly
a suggestion that's a bit too late but
not taking away any um credibility from
that suggestion
maybe that is something that could be
noted for
the next um annual report
yes chairman um
i i while understanding the points that
uh the members are raising
um the you know the the annual
the annual review is not supposed to be
a comprehensive you know
uh list of everything that's actually
you know being sort of
every point that's been raised during um
during sort of meetings
it is an overview of the work streams
throughout the year
um and i think that um
you know i can see i can see a benefit
of actually putting links and
that would be quite easy to do in the
electronic version of the document
to um you know two minutes of meetings
for example
um and that that you know that that's
not a that's not sort of difficult
thing to do and it uh it could be sort
of done at this uh
at this stage uh chairman if if the
committee's so wished
okay thank you sonya um councillor mrs
mason
yes if i can just um raise a question uh
conventionally on the last meeting of
the review committee
on a session we normally
put proposals forward for the
forthcoming
year will be that membership will
probably change dramatically
um i know it's not on the agenda mr
chairman but were you intending to do
that or have you
decided not to do that this year
uh thank you councilman mr jason no in
consultation
with sonia um we we are aware that some
members
actually have already made some
suggestions um that's
not something i was going to take
forward this evening um but it will be
something that
um the work plan those items will go on
to the work plan of the work plan will
be presented
at the next meeting that's corrected
sonia
just to make sure that i have advised
members correctly
yes as as as as as the councillor
correctly states the um
you know the membership will will change
um uh
in that you know at daniel council and
um
any any suggestions which um which
members wish to uh to to
email through will obviously be be
collated and we will
um we will produce a work plan for uh
for members consideration at the first
meeting in the new municipal year
thank you mr chairman as i say it's been
conventional for the
committee to do it to help the the new
committee coming in but if officers are
taking on that role that
i'm fine with sending uh emails to
officers
thank you thank you council mrs mason
me on
yeah thank you chairman um yeah it is a
a much more readable report
and it's sort of easy on the eye one
thing has occurred to me because
obviously the things that come into
review
are issues and we look at those issues
with a view to producing either a
critique
or batting it back to get some
resolutions or some
way forward issues and now we've
produced this
um it is a reference for next year in
that we
can have some sort of results analysis
of what the outcomes
are of this work that's been done i know
that sounds like another little work
stream but
quite quite often if something's totally
resolved it's not a problem
something's ongoing uh you see i mean
it's good business a good
sort of organizational practice to to
have that kind of facility because we've
done this work
we're moving on some of it will hang
over into
uh into 2022 and we can
look at this more like a kind of a
reference which gives us synopsis of
of the work that's done um and then if
anybody wants to research anything
further of course it's all in the in the
records of the council
it's all in the minutes and and in the
papers and reports
so from that point of view i'm just
suggesting or asking
how do we go about that kind of issue
you know that way
it is an ongoing narrative that's what
i'm saying but otherwise um
you know i'm quite pleased with it thank
you
thank you councilman i think overall the
the comments of the
this year's report are more positive
um than they are critical i'm sure that
um when it comes to producing next
year's report
there will be some slight changes made
to it by um
suggestions from the chairman or the
members um and i'm sure they'll be taken
on board and
possibly incorporated into into any
future reports
um but for now on a personal level like
i said we
i've thanked officers for their efforts
um and
on that basis with no more questions i'd
like to move that the
annual report be approved um
do i have a second at all
i'll the first hand i saw raised was
councillor mcpherson
and um members if it did anybody want a
recorded vote
taken
counsellor spirit and i think that
cancer sparing has his hand up
no no no
okay so i i'm not
receiving any indications that members
want a recorded vote
to be taken so in that case if members
are happy to
receive or recommend the report to full
council would you please raise your
raised hand icon
okay everybody i can see has raised
their hand with the exception
of um counselor hazelwood
if your raised hand icon isn't working
you're indicating to raise your hand
thank you
councillor hazelwood which i think makes
that a unanimous vote
sonia
um
is that correct sonia were you just
counting them then
chairman i uh i i counted 14 hands which
i think
is is unanimous okay well i've done the
same so my notes
agree with that okay members if you
could just lower your raise hand icon
and that um
that report will be going to full
council
for approval um
on that basis members because there is
no
um work plan or key decisions document
this month
oh councillor berry did you wish to
speak yeah
um just before you close chairman um
it might be slightly in the wrong order
on behalf of the conservative
councillors here i can't speak for my
other colleagues can i thank you for
your contributions as chairman over the
past few years and
uh i wish you every well and every
happiness in your
your life outside rochefort district
council good luck
thank you very much thank you um
very very very kind of you thank you um
it's well to be honest the meeting was
coming to an end i'll i won't
keep everybody much longer but yeah
obviously i'm i am
standing down this year um chairman of
review has been an absolute
pleasure um and an honor and one i've
been
um very pleased um
to carry out really it's been amazing
and thank you to all members for this
municipal year and previous municipal
years
whether or not we share the same
political views all the time or even
just the same
views on matters um i have
respected each one of you and your views
at your um your comments
um and i will miss all of you um thank
you sonia for stepping in
um this year for me when paul departed
um you've been a godsend thank you
and also councillor sparring um thank
you for being my advice for
um the last few years very helpful
so thank you all very much um councillor
uh mrs mason
yes council berta i'd just like to wish
you all the best for the future
thank you lovely thank you very much
that's very appreciated
council hookway
uh thank you jamie um likewise we
we enter the council at the same time
and we're both going to be leaving it at
the same time
i don't know if we've uh both achieved
everything that we wanted to after we've
been here but at least it's been
an interesting experience and uh um i'm
sure we happily have yeah
thank you yeah thank you council hookway
and and and likewise i wish anybody
who's not standing
um i wish you all the very best um
and i'm sure you know within the circle
of councils it will all probably
bump into each other speak to each other
or something along the lines of council
canal
yeah i had used the comment box um in
case we didn't get around to it but no
those comments as well like you say we
don't always have to agree politically
on everything
to recognize the contribution we make
and you have made a contribution to ross
for district council so on behalf of the
liberal democrats thank you
thank you it's very kind um
okay members um i wish you all and
uh genuinely mean each and every one of
you all the very best um
hopefully i will get to see you soon
probably sooner than some of you may
like i don't know
um but um thank you all for the seasons
meeting and for attending
um wish you all well for future um good
luck and take care everybody good night
good night
thank you jamie all right